welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and i don't know if you can see her
between the tears in your eyes but the
mcu's next iron man made her formal
debut in marvel studios first trailer
for the emotional roller coaster that is
going to be wakanda forever but a lot of
people are wondering how exactly a
random teenager from chicago is going to
end up getting herself involved in a war
between two of the most secretive
nations on earth in her first ever mcu
appearance and why is wakanda so crucial
to iron heart superhero origin in this
universe anyway let's speculate on it
together my nerd babies but first do not
forget to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com
to find all of our newest nerd gear
including our latest obsession shirts
like the thor love and thunder shirts
that are not going to be around forever
so pick one up today alright guys so i
think that ironheart is going to have to
get involved with the wakandans in the
mcu for two simple core reasons the
first one being that wakandan technology
is central to stark technology
specifically this heart-shaped piece of
technology on tony's chest in both
infinity war and endgame and two because
riri suit will be powered by the same
energy source as all of wakanda's stuff
and what karma in general so let's
tackle these one at a time starting with
the heart-shaped chest reactor that tony
had in avengers infinity war and end
game because a minor spoiler alert for
wakanda forever i guess but according to
recently revealed the merchandise for
the upcoming wakanda forever film we can
see that riri williams will apparently
be inheriting the same chess reactor
left behind by tony stark's barbecued
corpse and avengers endgame because lord
knows that uh that fried fellow don't
need nanotech no more the boy cooked and
the reason why this is significant to
riri's connection to wakanda and
potentially how riri's iron heart suit
will operate in the mcu is specifically
due to how tony stark made his super
nifty portable reactor suit in the first
place tony stark adapted wakandan
nanotechnology specifically after he
fought side by side with t'challa in
captain america civil war and before the
events of spider-man homecoming now if
you don't remember this happening don't
worry doctor strange didn't use the
runes of cough call on you it's actually
because this piece of data can actually
be found within a super dope and
informational mcu canon handbook called
the wakanda files and in this book all
about the technological side of the mcu
which is super interesting we learned
that after the events of civil war in
black panther tony stark immediately
started to see the benefits of wakanda
opening up their resources and
technology to the rest of the world by
receiving a special delivery of
nanotechnology from t'challa and shuri
themselves while stark industries also
openly shared their own r d data with
wakanda as well it was like a mutual
relationship of sharing information in a
voice note to jarvis tony says that i've
been thinking about how our friends sent
over the goods on that nanoparticle tech
the kid might benefit from a more
versatile and protective suit the kid of
course meaning spider-man and the more
versatile and protective suit of course
being the nanotech suit that tony
eventually makes for peter based on how
incredible he saw wakanda nanotech to be
the iron spider suit and of course after
this tony would make a nanosuit for
himself to match his spider-themed nerd
nephew that they could fight thanos
together in style courtesy of wakanda
you're welcome alright now let's get
into how tony stark's actual arc reactor
energy relates to wakanda because this
is actually quite significant because
remember that time when iron man 2 came
out and the novelization canonically
called the new element that tony stark
made based on howard stark's research on
the tesseract vibranium and then marvel
studios quickly tried to get everyone to
forget that that new element was called
vibranium by renaming it badassium later
on that was kind of sketchy right well i
think they did that sketchy [ __ ] for a
reason this video is brought to you by
the ridge the ridge wallet is light
sleek and industrial and it's designed
to fit in your front pocket unlike those
bulky old old school wallets that make
you look like you're smuggling an 80s
car phone in your back pocket it's
ridiculous check this out nice and sleek
there are over 30 colors and styles
including carbon fiber and bird's
titanium and it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash in the back and
every ridge wallet comes with a lifetime
guarantee and that lets you test drive
it for 45 days and send it back for a
full refund if you don't love it which
you will and the wallets have over 40
000 5 star reviews and it's made with
rfid blocking technology that protects
you from digital pickpocketers and they
also have other cool products like this
commuter backpack it's weatherproof and
great for toting around a laptop and
this month marks nine years since the
ridge started and they're celebrating
with a special sale so get 15 off today
with free worldwide shipping and free
returns by going to ridge.com new
rockstars that's ridge.com new rockstars
and use the code new rockstars find the
link in this video's description and we
thank ridge again for sponsoring this
video and that reason is they were
absolutely correct tony stark made
vibranium in iron man 2 and the clearest
example of this comes in the form of
marvel's what if episodes centering
around tony stark's close business
partnership with eric killmonger
specifically when the two are trying to
think of ways to power killmonger's
anime automatons of annihilation you
know we need another power source hey if
we could miniaturize an arc reactor
no that's a dumb idea what we need is
vibranium with the right juice it can
act as a self-sustaining energy source
too bad pops used up the last of it
during the war not all of it and i think
this moment is hilarious because tony
stark and eric killmonger essentially
had the same exact idea here but from
two different perspectives because tony
thought to miniaturize howard stark's
tesseract arc reactor and eric
killmonger thought to use actual
vibranium from the source and this is
why when tony goes to analyze
killmonger's vibranium ring the same
holographic imagery of howard stark's
new element appears around them because
it's the same [ __ ] like the atomic
structures of both of these are the same
because they're both the same power
source vibranium well specifically if
we're going to get technical gear the
blue tesseract dark energy vibranium can
harness for a multitude of different
energy applications like i'm telling you
guys once the tesseract popped onto the
scene on mcu earth everybody and their
mothers started going crazy over that
blue tesseract dark energy so much so
that they literally made an entire joint
dark energy mystery facility
specifically to pick up where howard
stark left off and it's the very same
place that wendy lawson and goose worked
out for decades until the 90s in the
same place that loki destroyed at the
beginning of avengers 1. because the
tester act is literally just a cube of
infinite amounts of dark energy and
vibranium can generate dark energy but
anyways this all being said knowing that
riri williams will likely be utilizing
tony's very same end-game arc reactor to
power her own suits i'm guessing that
riri suits will also rely on vibranium
nanotechnology that harnesses the same
energy that illuminates wakanda's
vibranium mines dark energy baby and
since tony stark is no longer around to
show re-read the secrets of vibranium
technology and its applications rio
williams is going to have to make a
visit to our next best option princess
shuri of wakanda the world's foremost
expert on vibranium in all of its
scientific applications but not only
this but shuri already has extensive
dealies with stark technology given how
we know that wakanda and stark
industries have been sharing data ever
since the events of civil war and also
you know shuri sort of did that whole
thing with vision and vision is
technically
a piece of stark property because it was
made by stock property but you know
technically helen joe made vision it's a
weird thing vision's got a lot of
parents
so there you have it iron heart and
wakanda are pretty much inextricably
linked in the mcu and i for one cannot
wait to see ironheart and shuri team up
together after shuri helps riri catch
the vibes of vibranium because my
goodness like two of the smartest women
in the world teaming up i'm all about
that [ __ ] especially because they're
brown like me let's go my sisters let's
change the world with science and
vibranium and dark energy and love this
[ __ ] and now i'll be the useless man
watching from the sidelines
but thank you guys so much for watching
this video you can follow me at
masterchain on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly you can follow new rock
stars wherever we are on social media
and when you do it on youtube make sure
you hit that notification bell so that
you can get notifications every time we
upload a video which is basically every
day but again thank you guys so much for
spending time with me i love you guys so
much and i'll see you guys next time
bye
[Music]
do what you guys need to do
you know what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying